[Music]
if you've ever taken a picture with an
animal you know just how unpredictable
they can be when it's time to pose they
like to look you in the face or run away
and hide completely ruin the shot but
sometimes animals pop up in your photos
without you even realizing it and the
results are hilarious if you're new to
our channel don't forget to subscribe
and please give this video a big thumbs
up today we'll be showing you pictures
of funny animals who don't know how to
mind their own business
a very loving pet there's a reason why
they call dogs a man and woman's best
friend dogs are lovable caring and
they're always in the mood to cuddle
sometimes when a dog messages owner a
little too much their display of
affection can be a little embarrassing
like this furry friend for example who
decided to take a clip where no dog
should ever be allowed to go he wanted
to take a quick sue and then and a woman
thought inviting a giraffe into their
photo would make for great pictures that
they could remember forever but this
giraffe had other plans in mind instead
of standing and posing in the background
he completely spilled the show by
shoving his head in between them and
showing off his big wet tongue for the
camera which you can barely see the
guy's face after the giraffe completely
dominated the entire photo-op taking a
cue we always got animals were pretty
innocent but this photo definitely has a
second guessing bit
when adjusts the wind
woman scared up the monkey was more
interested in what was going on
underneath just look at him you
completely ignoring the proof of
delicious fruit in at hand this is one
animal who definitely needs a lesson on
how to mind his own business this is my
good side setting the timer function on
your camera allows you to set up your
equipment run back into the frame and
capture the perfect shot but this nosy
dog made it his mission to completely
ruin the entire photograph as the woman
and boy sit in the background completely
oblivious as to what was going on the
dog moved in for his close-up but we
definitely think the camera captured his
good back how about you getting frisky
what was meant to be a cute and fun
photograph with a pair of eight turned
into a hilarious fiction that definitely
deserves to be framed this woman had
intentions on capturing the perfect shot
as she sat between cue a dressed in
their best outfit when the photographer
said he one of them got a bit handsy and
reached right for the woman's chest how
embarrassing
the right place the right time advances
in technology has made his waterproof
cameras all the rage for travelers with
the ability to stick close underneath
the water you can capture some pretty
amazing sights but this man's goal of
taking an underwater picture to make all
of his friends jealous was ruined when a
fish swam right into the shot oh well at
least it makes for a pretty funny
picture don't you think super kitty this
cat was determined not to let these
people enjoy their conversation in peace
while they chatted over dinner someone
took a candid photograph of the group
but they definitely weren't expecting to
see super kitty flying in the background
this picture was taken at just the right
moment to see the feline go airborne
photobomb the look on these women's
faces says it all
they're completely freaked out that a
stingray decided to photobomb their
perfect moment as they stand there
looking completely horrified and shocked
check out the ladies to the right they
can't even contain their laughter
which is these photos of funny animals
if you like the most
react in the comments section down below
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up
[Music]